leave nothing for tomorrow
which can be done today
nearly all men can stand adversity
but if you want to test a man's
character
give him power
give me six hours to chop down a tree
and i will spend the first four
sharpening the axe
the best way to predict your future
is to create it
better to remain silent and be thought
of fool
than to speak out and remove all doubt
no man is good enough to govern another
man
without the other's consent
that some achieve great success
is proof to all that others can achieve
it as well
i would rather be a little nobody than
to be an evil somebody
no man has a good enough memory to be a
successful liar
those who look for the baddened people
will surely find it
america will never be destroyed from the
outside
if we falter and lose our freedoms
it will be because we destroyed
ourselves
always bear in mind that your own
resolution to success
is more important than any other thing
in the end it is not the years in your
life that count
it's the life in your years
i don't like batman
i must get to know him better
things may come to those who wait
but only the things left by those who
hustle
whenever i hear anyone arguing for
slavery
i feel a strong impulse to see it tried
on him personally
[Music]
you can fool some of the people all of
the time and all of the people some of
the time
but you cannot fool all of the people
all of the time
i am rather inclined to silence
and whether that be wise or not
it is at least more unusual nowadays to
find a man who can hold his tongue
than to find one who cannot
we can complain because rose bushes have
thorns
or rejoice because thorn bushes have
roses
if i am killed
i can die but once
but to live in constant dread of it
is to die over and over again
in this sad world of ours
sorrow comes to all and
to the young
it comes with bitterst agony because it
takes them unawares
the older have learned to ever expect it
[Music]
do i not destroy my enemies
when i make them my friends
[Music]
i am a slow walker
but i never walk back
when you feel discouraged
seek healing in the labor
one day you will regret that you did not
hear these quotes earlier do not lose
the opportunity
watch our next video